Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Cette semaine, je suis allé à la rencontre de mon amie Julie Foulon, la cofondatrice de MolenGeek.
MolenGeek se trouve à Molenbeek, le fameux quartier bruxellois dont on a beaucoup parlé il y a quelques années.
On passe une heure à parler de ce très beau projet qui illustre encore une fois que l'informatique est un formidable vecteur d'ascension sociale,
mais aussi de l'entrepreneuriat en Belgique et du manque de femmes dans le secteur.
Et en parlant de ça, j'aurai une grosse annonce à faire en fin d'émission, donc reste bien jusqu'au bout. Let's go ! Et bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour un nouvel épisode.
Cette semaine, on passe septante minutes avec Julie Foulon. Salut Julie.
Salut Guillaume.
Très content de t'avoir. Ça fait des mois que je te cours après. On essaie de se caser un rendez-vous et on a enfin réussi à se poser deux heures à MolenGeek.
Tu es super occupée-
Ouais, très
...parce que tu diriges MolenGeek. C'est quoi MolenGeek ? Rappelle-nous.
MolenGeek, c'est un incubateur de start-up, c'est aussi une coding school. Donc la mission première de MolenGeek, c'est de rendre accessibles à tous les nouvelles technologies et l'entrepreneuriat innovant
et en particulier aux jeunes qui ont quitté l'école tôt,
qui sont soit en décrochage, soit qui n'arrivent pas à se,
à se projeter dans cette société, le marché du travail, parce qu'il y a vraiment une vraie différence entre ce que tu apprends à l'école et puis les besoins concrets des entreprises.
Donc il y a plein de jeunes comme ça-
Ouais
...qui sont un peu perdus. Et nous, on les accueille ici pour-
D'accord, ok
...leur donner une voix.
Beaucoup de choses dans ce que tu as dit. On va passer tout ça en revue. Mais ouais, donc on a parlé de MolenGeek avec Alexander De Croo dans l'épisode un.
On en a parlé avec Interface3 dans l'épisode deux.
Nous sommes omniprésents, c'est ça.
Ben oui, oui.
Ça, c'est MolenGeek.
Et donc tu arrives-- T'es un peu comme l'empereur dans Star Wars. On parle de toi pendant tous les épisodes et puis tu arrives dans l'épisode six. Voilà, et donc tu-
J'aime bien l'analogie.
C'est ça. Tu meurs à la fin, désolé.
Mais donc les jeunes qui arrivent à MolenGeek, tu m'expliquais que c'était des jeunes en-- Vous faisiez un focus sur ceux qui étaient un peu défavorisés, qui avaient un cursus scolaire un peu difficile.
C'est-- voilà, c'est qui précisément les jeunes qui viennent à MolenGeek ? Parce que ça me paraît assez typé.
J'étais dans la salle d'attente tout à l'heure et je voyais des filles, je voyais des gens de couleur, je voyais que des minorités qu'on voit pas d'habitude dans les milieux un peu tech.
Comment tu fais ? Comment c'est possible ?
Ben en fait, c'est parti un peu d'un constat. Donc l'idée de MolenGeek ne vient pas de moi, hein, ça vient d'Ibrahim Ouassari et d'une bande de copains.
Moi, je suis arrivée dans l'aventure vraiment au tout début, avant que ça prenne.
Et l'idée, c'était que-- En fait, si tu veux, je rebondis sur ce que tu disais, qu'on voit des gens qu'on voit pas dans la scène tech, c'est vrai, puisque la scène tech, d'une manière générale, est assez élitiste.
On voit toujours le même type de profil, des gens qui ont fait des études supérieures, qui viennent de classe moyenne, classe supérieure. Comme-
Au-delà du milieu d'où ils viennent, il y a un peu le côté cooptation. On s'invite entre mecs, entre Blancs, on reste bien entre nous et voilà.
Ben tout à fait. Ben de toute façon, tu le voyais bien un peu au Beta Group, hein, quand tu venais à mes événements.
Vas-y, balance, balance.
Hein, ben oui, c'est ça. C'est vrai qu'il y avait quoi ? Entre quatre cents, cinq cents personnes qui venaient tous les mois à l'ULB et tu voyais, c'était toujours le même type de pro-
...de profil. Très peu de femmes, comme tu dis, c'est principalement des hommes. Et puis ben, zéro diversité culturelle.
Alors moi, je râlais parce que je trouvais qu'il y avait pas assez de nanas. Et puis lui, Ibrahim, quand il venait à mes événements, il disait : « Ben écoute, finalement, il y a pas beaucoup de diversité non plus quoi ».
Et puis il y a pas non plus de jeunes. Et malgré le fait de le faire à l'université, je me souviens dans les statistiques, j'avais 7 % d'étudiants.
Ah ouais.
Ce qui est rien. Ce qui est rien du tout. Alors qu'on sait, l'innovation vient aussi des jeunes, de par leur manière de voir le monde, d'utiliser les nouvelles technologies.
Donc c'était très important de pouvoir les impliquer et les intégrer. Donc c'est vrai que MolenGeek, l'idée de base, c'était de faire un test à Molenbeek et de prouver que les jeunes, finalement, des quartiers,
avaient un intérêt et pouvaient accrocher à toutes ces nouvelles techniques entrepreneuriales et à cette innovation, ces nouvelles technologies.
Et donc on a vraiment transformé l'essai en créant un espace en mars 2016 qui a été agrandi de-- qui passait de soixante-cinq mètres carrés à cent septante, puis maintenant à six cents et bientôt à mille mètres carrés.
Ouah.
Et bientôt, on ouvrira encore un autre lieu. Donc c'est vrai qu'on a vraiment transformé l'essai dans le sens où
on a réussi à toucher toute une jeunesse qui, finalement, n'arrivait pas à se projeter dans l'avenir, dans le marché du travail et qui, finalement, avait,
avait que des perspectives d'avenir sur des travails, des-- tu vois, du travail à faible valeur ajoutée.
Des travaux, oui, style chauffeur de bus, etc.
Exactement.
C'est ça.
Alors que les nouvelles technologies, secteur d'opportunités et d'avenir, et on le sait, hein, dans les dix prochaines années, la moitié des nouveaux métiers, on les connaît pas encore et ce sera dans le digital.
Donc c'est un vecteur de croissance et c'est un vecteur d'émancipation.
C'est ça. Donc quand tu le décris comme ça, on a l'impression que les jeunes qui viennent ici, ils viennent chercher-- 'fin, y a pas que des jeunes, mais
les jeunes qui viennent ici, ils viennent chercher une espèce de levier d'ascension sociale, un petit peu du style : « Ben, j'ai pas envie de devenir chauffeur de bus.
J'aimerais bien avoir un métier qui paye bien, qui est valorisé dans la société » et ils viennent chercher ça.
Ben ils viennent surtout se raccrocher à quelque chose qui les intéresse. Donc ils ont tous un smartphone dans la poche, ils sont tous consommateurs de nouvelles technologies.
Et là, pour une fois, on leur dit : « Ben, vous savez, les nouvelles technologies, c'est pas si inaccessible que ça.
C'est pas parce qu'on parle anglais ou dans la scène tech, on utilise un vocabulaire assez compliqué ou des notions complexes à appréhender que c'est pas fait pour vous.
» Mais y a quand même pas mal de buzzwords et nous, on est là pour justement faire un peu le ménage et-
Faire le truc un peu accessible
...et rendre les choses accessibles. Et en fait, ça fonctionne puisque quand on voit les jeunes qui font notre coding school, en l'espace de six mois, ils deviennent full stack développeurs
et ils sont à la fin embauchés ou alors ils montent leur entreprise.
Donc tu penses que ça vient surtout d'une familiarité, d'un intérêt pour
les ordinateurs, pour les GSM et donc ouais, pas tellement pour les questions économiques de se dire : « J'ai envie d'avoir un métier cool qui paye bien et qui me plaît » et tout ça ?
Ben je pense qu'il y a un centre d'intérêt. Donc ils aiment bien, ils sont consommateurs, ils aiment bien les nouvelles technologies en général, sans savoir ce qu'est le métier de développeur, hein, par exemple. Et puis donc,
ils viennent ici,
ils se forment et après, évidemment, il y a toujours cette question économique parce que la plupart des jeunes qui viennent ici, ben, il faut quand même le reconnaître, hein, ils ont énormément de difficultés à être embauchés.
La plupart n'ont pas de diplôme. 30 %-
Avant de venir ici, ouais.
Voilà. 30 % des jeunes qui viennent ici n'ont pas de CESS. Et alors après, dans ceux qui ont leur CESS, ben alors là, la grande majorité n'ont pas fait d'études supérieures.
Donc autant te dire que c'est compliqué pour eux, ben, d'un point de vue diplôme, d'être embauchés, ils ont pas le bon profil.
Et alors en plus, tu mets une couche de discrimination, alors là, parfois, c'est mission impossible.
Donc du coup, ils sont obligés de se tourner vers l'entrepreneuriat. Et là, grande chance, c'est que pour être entrepreneur, t'as pas besoin de faire d'études parce que c'est une question d'état d'esprit avant tout.
Et les nouvelles technologies, ça avance tellement vite et ça évolue à une rapidité, donc ce que je disais, complètement dingue,
que si tu te formes et que tu mets le pied à l'étrier, que t'es motivé, que t'as un bon bosseur, eh ben grâce à l'expérience et ce que tu fais, ben tu peux devenir full stack développeur et combiner les deux.
Alors là, c'est le combo gagnant, tu montes ta boîte.
C'est ça. Mais quand tu parles de monter ta boîte, c'est plutôt alors des boîtes de services où tu es webmaster pour d'autres sociétés ou tu crées du...
Tout à fait. Alors au début, c'est vrai que c'est ça. Parce qu'il faut comprendre que t'as un cheminement.
Tu viens pas comme ça de rien du tout à l'idée du siècle qui va révolutionner la Terre entière. Donc les jeunes viennent ici, ils se familiarisent avec un écosystème tech et innovant,
ils se forment, ils deviennent indépendants, donc ils commencent à avoir leur premier client.
Alors, c'est souvent comme tu dis, hein, c'est la création de sites internet, la gestion de contenus, etc. Et c'est après, au travers d'un process que, ben là, ils commencent à développer leurs propres idées.
Mais ça prend du temps. Ça prend du temps, pour le coup, d'avoir une idée qui a mûri et qui a maturé.
Et c'est ça qui est intéressant avec MolenGeek, c'est que d'un côté, il y a cet aspect, on parle de start-up, de start-up nation, de grandes levées de fonds, etc.
Et en même temps, quand tu nous parles de tout ça, il y a un peu le côté social, un peu le côté... Vous avez reçu des aides du gouvernement de
la part du Digital Skills Fund d'Alexander De Croo il y a quelques années, donc
cinq cent mille euros, si je ne m'abuse.
Donc quand on entend ça, on se dit : « Ah, c'est vraiment côté social, côté on va aider la jeunesse. » Et puis-
Oui.
Et en même temps, il y a aussi cet aspect : on va créer de la valeur, on va créer des sociétés...
Ben c'est pour ça que nous, on parle plutôt d'un impact sociétal positif. Donc c'est vrai que la première année, on a eu vraiment de l'aide d'Alexander De Croo, au travers de son fonds, hein.
Et c'est vrai que ça nous a permis finalement d'avoir un impact plus grand et vraiment positif et de mettre vraiment un grand coup et de permettre de lancer MolenGeek, ce qui est chouette.
C'est vrai qu'on continue à être aidés à ce niveau-là, mais on a cette logique
d'entrepreneur avec Ibrahim où notre objectif, c'est d'être indépendant financièrement et afin justement de grandir comme une vraie entreprise et de montrer l'exemple à tous ces jeunes.
On n'est pas là pour...
C'est ça, pour vivre des subsides.
Ah non, pas du tout.
Définitivement.
Ah pas du tout.
Mais justement, j'avais une question là-dessus puisque donc vous êtes aussi soutenus par des grands géants américains du style
Google, Samsung et donc aussi des grandes sommes d'argent, plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros.
Cet argent, il part où, en fait ? Parce que je vois des agrandissements, des étages qui bougent, mais est-ce que vous avez vraiment dépensé près d'un million d'euros dans ce que je vois là ici ?
Ou comment ça marche ?
Ah ben, on n'a pas reçu un million d'euros de Samsung et de Google.
Non, non, mais si on ajoute les cinq cent mille d'Alexander De Croo, si on ajoute les deux cent, trois cent, je ne sais pas combien de Google et puis ceux de Samsung et puis voilà.
Alors donc déjà, on a fait tous les travaux d'agrandissement du rez-de-chaussée. Donc ça, c'était quand même un grand bloc, hein.
Ouais, ça s'est bien agrandi depuis, hein.
Si tu te souviens, mais dans le bâtiment dans lequel nous nous trouvons, qui est le centre d'entreprises de Molenbeek, c'était vraiment des bureaux qui étaient séparés les uns des autres.
Donc ça, c'était vraiment-- on est passé de soixante-cinq mètres carrés à cent septante mètres carrés. Donc on a changé complètement la structure.
Et puis après, on s'est agrandis de quasiment quatre cents-- un peu plus de quatre cents mètres carrés supplémentaires au premier étage.
Donc pareil, il a fallu changer la structure pour passer de bureaux individuels à un grand espace de coworking d'un côté et puis des classes vitrées de l'autre.
Donc tu vois, ça demande aussi pas mal d'investissements. Puis après, on a aussi du personnel, hein, on a des coachs, il y a du monde, hein, qui travaille à MolenGeek.
Des ressources humaines et des bâtiments, et du matériel et tout ça.
Et puis des événements, beaucoup d'événements qu'on organise, hein. Donc il y a toutes les activités qu'on organise à MolenGeek, évidemment.
Ouais. Mais donc du coup, ça marche comment le modèle économique de MolenGeek ? Puisque tu m'as expliqué qu'à terme, vous voulez devenir rentable, vous voulez rentrer dans vos frais.
Jusque-là, vous avez surtout des aides gouvernementales, des aides de sponsors. On a dit Google, Samsung et compagnie.
Vous allez faire comment du coup ?
Ben c'est vrai qu'avec Ibrahim, on a cette logique entrepreneuriale qu'on a eue depuis le début. Comme tu dis, on a différents revenus qui sont assez variés.
On a de l'aide de l'État, hein, donc de ce fonds d'Alexander De Croo, le Digital Skills Fund. On a aussi, comment dire, des subsides de la région Bruxelles-Capitale pour des projets très particuliers.
On a des gros sponsors, Samsung et Google, mais on est aussi prestataire de services pour Bruxelles Formation et Actiris, puisqu'on crée et on donne des formations pour les chercheurs d'emploi.
Enfin, là, on développe ce qu'on appelle une factory où on crée des sites internet et des applications pour les entreprises et les entreprises nous rémunèrent.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on va vraiment essayer de faire développer par la suite pour être complètement indépendants et ne plus faire appel aux subsides de l'État quoi.
OK, donc si je comprends bien-- 'fin, tu peux expliquer un peu la factory, ça marche comment ? C'est...
Ben la factory, donc c'est un nouveau service, hein, qu'on a lancé. Et l'idée, c'est que des entreprises qui souhaitent faire développer une application ou un site Internet, ben le fassent au travers de MolenGeek.
Et donc nous, on met des gens pour faire développer
ces applications. Alors ce qui est chouette, c'est que ces entreprises, pourquoi est-ce qu'elles viennent chez nous et pas aller voir des, je sais pas, des web agencies qui ont pignon sur rue ?
C'est que souvent, ces entreprises trouvent que le travail qu'on fait est intéressant et que ça participe à l'écosystème, à le faire évoluer.
Puis en plus, c'est souvent des juniors, ils le savent, hein. Ce sont des juniors qui vont développer les sites et les applications, supervisés par des seniors.
Et du coup, ça permet finalement l'apprentissage et l'acquisition de compétences.
Cool. On va passer alors sur les formations que vous faites ici à MolenGeek, dans la coding school. Vous en faites deux par an, deux fois six mois, avec à chaque fois des classes de un peu moins de vingt personnes. C'est ça ?
Non, on fait plus que ça. La première année, on a fait deux classes pilotes-
Ouais.
Donc en 2017. Et notre objectif en 2018, c'est faire cinq classes et puis après, d'augmenter.
D'accord, donc vous augmentez vraiment le-
Ouais, ouais
...le niveau. Et toujours pour des-
Ben oui, puisqu'on a surtout-
Oui, oui.
Tu vois, on a maintenant toute l'infrastructure nécessaire pour assurer plein de classes supplémentaires.
Oui, c'est toujours des formations de six mois alors.
C'est toujours des formations de six mois. Donc comme je disais, t'as les quatre premiers mois, l'idée, c'est d'apprendre les langages de programmation et puis les deux derniers mois, c'est être en production.
Oui. Il me semblait avoir entendu Ibrahim dire que peut-être que six mois, c'était un peu limite, qu'il fallait peut-être augmenter un peu la durée.
Qu'est-ce que-- vous en êtes où à ce niveau-là ?
Eh ben non, c'est toujours six mois. Donc ceux qui veulent continuer après, ils continuent leur stage. Ils ont la possibilité de faire un stage.
C'est ça. Oui, et en plus de ça, ils ont possibilité d'être rémunérés, j'imagine. Non ?
Ben non, ils font un stage, c'est pas rémunéré.
Un stage rémunéré ?
Non.
OK. Non, non ? OK.
Ils sont en apprentissage.
Donc dans ces formations, l'année dernière, quand c'était seulement des classes de dix-neuf personnes, vous aviez huit filles sur les dix-neuf élèves, donc à peu près 40 % de la classe.
Comment vous faites ? Comment c'est possible ? Parce que des filles, y en a pas en informatique d'habitude.
Eh ben là, y en a, figure-toi.
Et comment c'est possible ?
Ben justement, on va les chercher là où on s'y attend pas.
La majorité des femmes qui sont là dans la dernière promotion, même dans les précédentes, hein, ben c'est pas du tout des femmes qui avaient des compétences tech à la base.
C'était des femmes, ben voilà, qui cherchaient un peu une voie et qui ont entendu parler de MolenGeek, qui se sont dit : « Ben voilà, pourquoi pas ? »
C'est ça.
« Pourquoi pas ? »
Quand tu me dis ça, j'ai l'impression qu'il y a une grande différence entre—— tu sais, moi, j'étais en informatique à l'ULB et donc t'avais un auditoire de
cent mecs qui avaient baigné dans l'informatique, dans les ordinateurs depuis dix ans et qui jouaient aux jeux vidéo et qui étaient à fond super geek et tout.
Et j'ai l'impression que toi, tu me décris des filles qui viennent surtout parce qu'elles ont envie de trouver une voie, trouver un métier, trouver quelque chose qui peut
les sortir d'une situation un peu peut-être plus difficile, voilà, sortir du chômage, par exemple.
Et donc c'est vraiment une logique de comment est-ce que je vais ramener de l'argent à la maison plutôt que de se dire : « Ah moi, ça me passionne, c'est mon truc, je suis à fond dedans. »
Ben c'est une logique d'émancipation. Elles se disent——
C'est ça.
Elles voient—— on parle, nous, à MolenGeek, on parle de programmation informatique, d'entrepreneuriat, du fait que c'est accessible, etc.
Et donc le message, visiblement, est entendu, ben par ces femmes, notamment. Et elles essayent. Et puis elles passent les tests.
Et puis ça fonctionne. Et puis elles se découvrent. En fait, si tu veux, c'est vraiment des femmes qui connaissaient pas.
Et parce qu'elles n'avaient jamais testé, parce qu'on a toujours autour d'elles, on leur a toujours dit que le code, c'était pour les mecs, que l'entrepreneuriat, c'est pour les hommes.
Et en venant ici, ben elles se sont révélées et ce sont d'excellentes développeuses.
Je me souviens avoir discuté avec Soumaya et elle m'expliquait qu'elle était avant dans une haute école et qu'il y a eu un genre de
projet de loi ou un truc qui était voté et qui faisait qu'on ne pouvait plus venir avec son voile, son hijab, à l'école et que donc elle pouvait plus aller, elle pouvait plus poursuivre ses études.
Donc, elle s'est retrouvée ici un peu par contrainte. Donc, vous récupérez un petit peu aussi les pots cassés de l'enseignement, j'allais dire officiel, mais l'enseignement supérieur plutôt.
Bah oui, mais c'est—— franchement, cette histoire-là, justement, t'en parles, bah moi, je trouve que c'est vraiment dramatique et puis je trouve ça vraiment stupide, bah, de rejeter finalement les gens par rapport à
à ce qu'ils peuvent m'apporter.
Et c'est vraiment la spécificité de MolenGeek. Nous, on regarde pas ton identité, on regarde ce que tu sais faire.
Et je pense que c'est pour ça que la communauté est tellement appréciée et c'est pour ça que les gens se sentent bien, parce qu'on n'est pas là en train de te questionner sur qui t'es, sur tes diplômes,
mais plutôt sur ce que tu sais faire.
Ah bah, t'es passionné de réalité virtuelle. Ah bah toi, t'aimes bien la 3D. Ah bah toi, t'es un bon développeur. Eh bah, c'est ça qui intéresse les gens.
Alors, ce qui est rigolo, c'est qu'après coup, des mois plus tard, moi, ça m'est déjà arrivé, bah, de m'apercevoir que j'avais des collaborateurs qui n'avaient pas de CESS, par exemple.
Parce qu'on s'en fout.
Le CESS pour les Français qui nous écoutent, c'est le bac.
Voilà.
C'est le truc que tu reçois à 18 ans.
Exactement. Et nous, on s'en fout. Le but, c'est vraiment : bah qu'est-ce que tu sais faire et qu'est-ce que tu peux amener à la communauté pour qu'on s'entraide tous et qu'on y ait cet effet de levier.
Et que si j'apprends quelque chose, bah, et que je te le transmets, ça te profitera et ça profitera sûrement à ton voisin.
Et puis il y aura peut-être un retour de boomerang et ça me profitera, ça nous profitera à tous. Donc c'est pour ça que, par exemple, quand tu viens ici, t'as pas ce sentiment de compétition, même au sein de la Coding School.
Tout le monde est là pour s'entraider et pour faire du business.
Ouais, il y a une espèce de sentiment de fraternité, de——
Tout à fait. Et de profondément respect.
Mh.
Donc c'est vrai que—— donc nous, on récupère pas, comme tu dis, hein, enfin les pots cassés, mais on est une alternative.
Un peu quand même.
Bah, on est une vraie alternative et on donne une vraie réponse.
C'est vraiment intéressant ça, parce que donc il y a
il y a toutes ces personnes, moi y compris, qui se disent qu'il serait vraiment temps que l'enseignement obligatoire commence à donner des cours de programmation, qu'on commence à parler d'un peu plus d'entrepreneuriat, de choses comme ça.
Et c'est un milieu qui est très conservateur, qui est très inerte à toutes ces choses-là. Et donc tant que c'est comme ça, finalement, il y aura du monde pour venir à MolenGeek.
Mais si un jour on a une culture de l'entrepreneuriat, on a des cours de programmation à l'école, etc., ben il y aura peut-être un peu moins de—— un rôle un peu moindre à jouer, non ?
Ouais, bah peut-être qu'on changera alors notre fusil d'épaule, mais je crois qu'on a un peu le temps parce que comme tu dis——
Lâchement, surtout en Belgique
...je pense que même en Belgique ou en France, on n'y est pas du tout, on n'y est pas du tout. Puis alors nous,
n'oublie pas que nous, notre cible aussi, c'est pour les formations de développement web, c'est et d'applications, c'est les chercheurs d'emploi, hein, notre cible.
Pour l'instant, on n'est pas du tout encore au niveau des écoles. Même si on le fait, on accueille des écoles très régulièrement pour faire de la promotion des nouvelles technologies.
Quand j'avais rencontré Alexander De Croo, il décrivait les projets comme MolenGeek comme étant un petit peu des laboratoires qu'il finançait avec son fonds fédéral.
Donc, il a pas vraiment d'influence sur les écoles, mais donc il voit MolenGeek et les initiatives de ce style, parce qu'il y en a d'autres, comme des laboratoires. Et il espère,
j'étais un peu moyennement convaincu quand il m'a dit ça, mais il espère qu'à terme, ça va montrer au secteur de l'enseignement que
on peut apprendre des choses en termes pédagogiques, puisqu'on peut en parler aussi, mais la pédagogie ici est très intéressante.
On en a parlé un peu avec Nicolas Rolland. Mais donc, il espère qu'à terme, le secteur de l'enseignement obligatoire va apprendre un peu de MolenGeek.
Oui, ben on espère aussi. Si on peut inspirer, ce serait formidable, hein. C'est vrai que nous, encore une fois, notre but premier, c'est rendre accessibles les nouvelles technologies et l'entrepreneuriat à tous.
On n'est pas focalisés sur les écoles pour le moment parce qu'on a suffisamment à faire avec les chercheurs d'emploi.
Parce qu'elles sont très inertes et qu'elles ont pas forcément envie de——
Bah, c'est compliqué. Déjà, nous, on a un impact sur les, bah déjà sur les étudiants, sur les jeunes qui sont en secondaire parce qu'ils viennent ici.
Après, maintenant, il y a tout un travail pédagogique à faire aussi avec les professeurs et puis après avec les équipes pédagogiques, mais ça prend du temps.
Ça, il faudrait voir avec Nicolas Rolland, effectivement.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Le futur pour MolenGeek, c'est quoi ? Donc tu as parlé d'ouvrir un deuxième lieu à Schaerbeek, c'est ça ?
À Schaerbeek, autour de la thématique du new media. Donc ça, c'est une chouette thématique. Mais les clés, on les a pas encore.
On les a en septembre.
D'accord. Ah bah oui, donc c'est tout bientôt quoi. C'est dans——
Ouais
...deux jours.
Ouais, c'est ça. On les a là. Et puis après, il faut faire des travaux. Puis on pourra installer un nouveau MolenGeek autour de la thématique du new media.
Alors, new media, c'est quoi ? C'est toutes les thématiques qui sont liées à la postproduction, au community management, à la création de contenu, au copywriting, etc.
OK. Donc une nouvelle délocalisation à Schaerbeek, pas loin d'ici. Et d'autres projets d'agrandissement. On m'a parlé de trucs en Italie, on m'a parlé du Maroc.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Alors effectivement, bah ça, c'est deux projets. T'as TechStation Padova à Padoue, en Italie. Et donc là, c'est trois entrepreneurs qui ont décidé de monter un MolenGeek là-bas.
OK. C'est où ? C'est—— Padova, c'est dans le sud, c'est dans le nord ?
C'est dans le nord, c'est à côté de Venise.
OK, d'accord. Donc c'est quoi ? C'est qu'ils ont entendu parler de vous dans la presse internationale, puisque comme on disait, vous faites beaucoup de presse.
Ils se sont dit : ''On va faire pareil.''
Eh bah, c'est les deux. En fait, figure-toi que ce sont des entrepreneurs qui sont dans le milieu des nouvelles technologies et qui recherchaient des compétences tech.
On le sait, hein, la Commission européenne n'arrête pas de le dire, il y a une pénurie de développeurs. Eh ben, ça a touché aussi l'Italie.
Et donc, ils cherchaient un peu sur la toile comment ils pouvaient, bah tu vois, trouver des programmes qui permettraient de former des jeunes aux langages de programmation.
Et puis ils nous ont découverts, puis ils sont venus, puis ça a bien accroché et on a décidé de les coacher et de leur permettre de, bah tu vois, de monter d'une manière totalement indépendante un MolenGeek en Italie.
Alors, ça s'appelle pas MolenGeek Italie——
Padova
...ça s'appelle TechStation Padova parce que le lieu, c'est dans une ancienne gare. Et effectivement, puis nous, ça nous apprend, on se forme hein, justement, à coacher une équipe bis, finalement, à développer un nouveau MolenGeek.
Quand tu dis coacher et former un nouveau MolenGeek, ça veut dire dans le sens où vous les formez en termes de pédagogie, comment enseigner le coding de manière efficace à des populations un peu défavorisées, c'est ça ?
En fait, on partage nos outils, bah nos outils, la pédagogie, les cours, les outils pour développer des événements, etc., pour qu'ils arrivent à répliquer un MolenGeek là-bas.
OK.
C'est une sorte de franchise, en fait.
Oui, d'accord, une franchise. Ouais, ça, c'est intéressant. Mais c'est juste un peu fou quand tu dis : ''On va leur donner notre façon de faire des cours——
Ouais.
...notre façon de faire une pédagogie.'' Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire exactement ?
Ben, par exemple, on a développé tout un tas de, ben, notre cours pour devenir développeur full stack, par exemple.
On le partage avec eux. On partage aussi notre méthodologie pour monter des événements type hackathon, pour développer une communauté de rien du tout——
OK.
...pour communiquer, et cetera. Donc c——
C'est marrant, parce que quand tu me dis ça, je me dis : ''Mais c'est pas si dur que ça. Pourquoi est-ce qu'ils doivent aller chercher en Belgique pour trouver
comment apprendre à programmer ?'' Je veux dire, on n'a pas attendu MolenGeek pour faire ça.
Non, mais on a développé toute une pédagogie, une méthodologie complètement innovante que——
Tu peux nous en parler ? Parce que c——
De la méthodologie ? Ouais, je peux en parler. Ben effectivement, si tu veux, la force de MolenGeek, c'est que tout le staff qui est là, on est tous indépendants, on est tous des entrepreneurs.
Et Yassine Karchaf, le directeur de la coding school, a développé donc tout le programme et c'est un passionné de pédagogie.
Donc il n'a pas du tout appris les langages de programmation à l'école. C'est un autodidacte. Lui, il a un bachelier en communication à la base.
Ah ouais OK.
Puis il est devenu entrepreneur, il a monté sa boîte,
et il a développé en fonction vraiment du public qu'on avait, donc des jeunes qui ont décroché l'école jeunes, assez tôt parce qu'ils en avaient marre d'apprendre des trucs complètement abstraits.
Il a développé une manière de faire qui est basée sur des cas concrets et une approche par la pratique. Donc t'as un peu de théorie, beaucoup de pratique.
Et donc en faisant ça, il a développé tout un tas de cours avec un vocabulaire précis, avec une arborescence précise, et cetera,
et qui fait en sorte que, ben, les jeunes deviennent autonomes très rapidement, apprennent à apprendre par eux-mêmes, ont un sentiment d'engagement et arrivent finalement, au terme des six mois, à être complètement
autonomes en tant que full stack développeur.
C'est super intéressant.
Et il a vraiment développé une méthodologie qui est complètement innovante et particulière et qui fonctionne, puisque maintenant, là, on va avoir notre cinquième promotion.
Donc ça, par exemple, on les coache. Et puis on les coache aussi à devenir, à créer cette communauté.
Et donc vous en faites un peu une franchise, vous vous délocalisez. Donc tu me parlais aussi du Maroc.
Ouais.
Un autre projet. Tu peux nous en parler ?
Alors, le Maroc, oui. Là, maintenant, on a fait deux événements avec nos amis marocains et Startup Maroc et l'APEFE.
L'APEFE qui est un peu la coopération belge.
Et ben l'idée, c'est vraiment de créer à Oujda, donc dans l'Oriental, hein, donc c'est vraiment le nord du Maroc,
un MolenGeek qui sera là-bas, un MolenGeek bis, hein, et qui permettra en fait aux jeunes,
marocains, ben, de se former aux nouvelles technologies, et de développer leur projet entrepreneurial et puis d'avoir un point de chute aussi à Bruxelles.
Et comme nous, les jeunes de, comment ça s'appelle, de Belgique, de Bruxelles, avoir un point de chute à Oujda.
Alors pourquoi Oujda ?
Ouais, pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il se trouve qu'il y a plein, comment dire, dans les flux migratoires des Marocains qui sont venus en Belgique,
c'est principalement des gens de l'Oriental, du nord donc du Maroc, qui sont venus à Bruxelles.
Et donc quand t'as des jeunes qui sont là et qui repartent en vacances au Maroc, ils repartent dans cette région.
Ouais.
Et donc il y a beaucoup plus de chances que ces jeunes puissent retrouver, ben, d'autres collègues avec qui ils ont participé à des événements type hackathon là-bas.
Qu'est-ce qui explique qu'ils retournent là-bas alors qu'ils n'y sont jam—— ils sont pas nés là-bas ? Ils——
Ben ils ont de la famille, tu vois, ils ont des grands-parents, des oncles, des tantes, et cetera. Tu vois, ils ont un point de...
Souvent, ils ont un point de chute, tu vois.
Un point de chute.
Ils viennent voir les cousins, tout ça.
OK, OK. Donc ça fait des liens entre Molenbeek et le Maroc. Et donc on——
Voilà. Et du coup, c'est chouette parce qu'en plus de ça, on a vraiment envie que Oujda, donc la région de l'Oriental qui est assez sinistrée,
ben de permettre finalement que cette ville soit un peu la porte d'entrée vers la région du MENA.
Donc c'est Middle East North Africa. Et d'être un point d'entrée vers l'Afrique et puis, ben, toute la région du Maghreb.
Tu fais aussi, en plus de MolenGeek, tu fais un truc qui s'appelle Girl Geek.
Ouais.
De temps en temps. Ça devient plus rare parce que t'es très occupée avec MolenGeek. Et donc tu fais des events où tu invites des gens de la scène de Bruxelles——
...et en particulier des femmes.
Oui.
Tu décris le truc comme étant le seul event tech avec une majorité de femmes et souvent, c'est vrai.
Ah ben, quand même, hein.
Mais comment tu fais ? Enfin, c'est genre, oui, comme tu disais, ça existe plus maintenant, mais quand on allait à Beta Group, y avait pas de filles, quand on allait,
au Coastation ou quoi, y en a quelques-unes, mais pas trop.
Et puis là, y en a, tu vois, y en a plein. Mais tu les trouves où ? Comment ça marche ?
Ben parce que voilà, on arrive à créer un environnement qui est suffisamment sympa et puis accueillant et qui permet, je pense, aux femmes de se reconnaître dans des événements tech.
C'est vrai que j'en fais plus beaucoup, hein, j'avoue, j'ai plus le temps, mais je me contente, ben, de l'écriture ou maintenant de la radio.
Ouais, moi aussi.
Mais c'est vrai qu'on arrivait à faire des trucs assez sympas. Mais ça prend du temps et ça demande beaucoup de ressources pour communiquer dans différents réseaux.
Oui, c'est juste le fait de faire un event par une fille, avec des logos, avec un style très féminin, avec des,
les filles en tête et le fait de dire : ''C'est pour vous, on vous cible directement.'' Ça, c'est ça qui ramène des filles ?
Je pense qu'on arrive à créer aussi des rôles modèles accessibles. Tu vois, dans le milieu de la tech, j'ai beau faire tout un tas de conférences, à chaque fois, c'est toujours le même rôle modèle qui,
qui vient, c'est Marie Curie.
Donc, tu vois, ça entend. Et en fait, la tech, c'est pas ça, hein. Il faut arriver à créer des rôles modèles accessibles.
Et les événements Girl Geek, c'est ça qui était chouette, c'est que t'avais tout un tas de nanas qui venaient, ben qui parlaient de nouvelles technologies, de leur start-up.
T'avais aussi des femmes qui venaient présenter aussi des entreprises qui sont a priori pas tech au début,
mais qui ont un pied dans l'entrepreneuriat au travers d'applications qui permettent, je sais pas, moi, de customiser, je sais pas, moi, des produits, par exemple, tu vois.
Et du coup, ça crée en fait un lien et puis un sentiment de reconnaissance, ben d'autres femmes qui se disaient : « Ah, mais attends, ça, c'est une entrepreneuse de la tech.
Ah, ça, c'est une tech girl, par exemple. Ben moi aussi, je fais la même chose. Donc moi, j'en suis une ». Tu vois ?
Donc ça, ça crée du lien.
Un office.
Et c'est aussi comme ça à MolenGeek, hein, qu'on arrive à attirer d'autres femmes dans les formations. Ben, c'est justement en créant ces rôles modèles accessibles.
Et comment est-ce que tu expliques qu'il y ait aussi peu de femmes entrepreneuses ? Comment ça se fait que ça reste globalement surtout un truc de mecs ici en Belgique ?
Entrepreneuses dans les technos ou quoi ?
En fait, les deux, quoi, de manière générale et encore plus dans les technos, quoi.
Ben moi, je pense que t'as des femmes qui se reconnaissent pas en tant qu'entrepreneuses tech, qui se définissent pas tant comme telles.
Donc déjà, t'as une chose, hein. Et puis alors après, on a un gros problème au niveau de l'entrepreneuriat pour les femmes, c'est, ben, c'est la famille, hein.
Alors déjà, en Belgique, les gens n'aiment pas prendre de risques. Quand tu dis : « Je vais devenir entrepreneur », ben toi, t'as fait l'expérience avec tes parents.
Quand t'as dit que tu voulais devenir entrepreneur, bon, ils se sont un peu affolés, n'est-ce pas ?
Ouais, ouais.
Et c'est vrai que souvent, on est un peu taxé de complètement frappadingue, de prendre des risques inutilement et qu'on devrait devenir consultant et d'avoir notre maison et notre voiture, ce serait beaucoup mieux.
Hum, hum.
Mais l'état d'esprit est en train de changer. Enfin, je l'espère. Et c'est vrai que quand t'es une femme, pour l'avoir expérimenté également, c'est que les gens autour de toi qui t'aiment et qui t'adorent,
ils projettent leur peur.
Donc, ils vont te dire : « Mais non, le fais pas, mais tu prends des risques, mais ça va pas fonctionner ». Alors, c'est pas-
Plus que quand t'es un homme.
Ah ben écoute, c'est compliqué.
Ouais.
Quand t'es une femme, c'est compliqué. Et souvent, je dis d'ailleurs : « Si vous êtes célibataire, c'est peut-être le meilleur moyen de devenir entrepreneur.
Au moins, vous avez pas de comptes à rendre et vous avez pas un mec qui va vous emmerder toutes les deux minutes ».
Tu peux avoir un bon mec. Tu peux bien choisir aussi.
Ouais, d'accord. Ben, je veux bien avoir des exemples. Donc appel à témoins.
Ouais.
N'hésitez pas à m'envoyer des cas. Non, mais c'est compliqué. C'est vrai que c'est pas facile pour une femme.
Et puis en plus, ben il faut le reconnaître, les femmes, elles sont quand même cantonnées à toutes les, à comment dire, à toutes les tâches ménagères.
Quand t'es maman, ben tu dois aussi-
OK.
Moi, je suis maman, je suis maman célibataire. Donc, je sais de quoi je parle, hein. Je dois cumuler et MolenGeek et Girl Geek et ma fille. C'est compliqué.
OK. Mais tu penses qu'il y a vraiment encore un héritage un peu très conservateur dans les mentalités ? Enfin, il reste un peu des choses de ce vieux monde-là, de se dire-
Oui.
La femme, la famille, la maman, l'épouse.
L'accès au financement, tout est plus compliqué quand t'es une femme.
Comment ça se fait, ça ? L'accès à quel financement ?
Ben par exemple, si t'as envie d'aller voir ton banquier pour avoir un prêt.
D'accord, ouais.
Tout est beaucoup plus compliqué quand t'es une femme.
Ouais, ouais. Et c'est d'ailleurs intéressant. Quand on pose cette question-là, on voit un petit peu deux grandes familles de féministes.
Comment est-ce qu'on fait, quand on est une femme pour résoudre ce problème de, ben justement d'avoir des investisseurs, des banquiers qui sont plus froids, qui sont moins enclins à te donner un financement que si tu étais un homme ?
C'est quoi la solution pour ça ?
Avoir des clients. Ben c'est simple. C'est, ben, c'est avoir des clients.
D'accord, mais si tu veux faire une start-up et que tu veux démarrer et que tu as besoin de faire des investissements de base dès le début, c'est...
Ben ouais, c'est quoi, ben c'est, ouais, c'est compliqué. J'ai pas vraiment la réponse.
Ben parce que je me souviens que j'étais venu à un event Girl Geek et il y avait Claire Munck qui avait expliqué que-
De Be Angel, ouais.
Ouais, qui avait expliqué qu'une solution, c'était de,
d'apprendre aux femmes à connaître leur public, à savoir que les investisseurs sont très probablement des hommes, que donc il faut pitcher avec un discours masculin et qu'il faut vendre des aspects masculins, connaître le... Voilà.
Ah mais effectivement, moi, je me souviens de cet événement-là. C'est vrai qu'on... Alors, je pense que certains de tes auditeurs seront pas d'accord, mais on vit dans un monde à discrimination positive envers les hommes.
Ils seront tous d'accord.
Donc, on vit dans un monde essentiellement masculin, avec des codes masculins, etc. Donc du coup, il faut, ben il faut parler le même langage.
Hum, hum.
Et euh, ben c'est compliqué. Ben il faut être-
C'est pour ça que je disais qu'il y avait deux grandes familles de féministes. C'est qu'il y a cette approche-là, qui est se dire : « Mais il faut, on est obligé, il faut faire avec, il faut,
faut se démener, mais voilà, on est quand même un peu obligé de faire comme ça ».
Puis, il y a l'autre famille qui est de dire : « Mais fuck 'em ». Tu vois, c'est genre si les hommes, ils veulent pas entendre notre discours, enfin
le discours des femmes, leur façon d'exprimer, leur façon de penser l'entrepreneuriat, de penser la technologie, c'est les hommes qu'il faut remettre en question et pas les femmes.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
OK. Et tu fais comment alors pour les remettre en question ?
C'est dur, hein. Mais c'est ce que je veux dire, c'est que y a une f-- on pourrait dire que c'est un petit peu baisser les bras que de dire : « Je vais parler comme un homme pour essayer d'avoir mon financement ».
Ouais, mais après, tu peux avoir le financement et après essayer de changer les choses avec ton point de vue.
Oui. OK. OK, c'est intéressant.
Oui, non, c'est pas facile. J'pense que, quand t'es entrepreneur, c'est suffisamment compliqué.
Tu vois, le fait de baisser les-- 'fin, de dire, de tout remettre en question, de baisser les bras, etc. Ça demande aussi beaucoup d'énergie.
Et cette énergie, finalement, tu pourrais la concentrer, l'utiliser pour faire avancer ton projet. Et si une fois, tu dois pitcher comme un mec pour avoir des fonds, bah, fais-le quoi, tu vois ?
Ok, ouais, c'est une approche. Tu en connais beaucoup des femmes entrepreneuses qui ont décroché un financement, qui ont levé des fonds ? Tu en connais ?
Bah, j'en connais, ouais, j'en connais, j'en connais quand même.
Et c'est plutôt quel profil ? C'est des gens qui viennent de Molenbeek ou c'est des gens qui viennent de Uccle ?
Non, c'est plutôt des universitaires de Torrens.
D'accord, ok. C'est ça. Qui ont fait Vlerick.
Ouais, ouais, ou plutôt ou l'ULB, etc.
D'accord, OK.
Ben donc on-- c'est intéressant parce qu'on parlait un petit peu du fait qu'en Belgique, voilà, culture de-- 'fin peur de la culture du risque, peur de l'échec, on a peur de se lancer et puis les femmes encore plus, etc.
Je me souviens que, je crois que c'était en mars dernier ou en avril, il y a eu un dossier dans La Libre Belgique, où vous étiez en une et vous parliez de Bruxelles et de la scène à Bruxelles, de Molenbeek, de MolenGeek, etc.
Vous aviez expliqué que Bruxelles allait devenir la nouvelle Silicon Valley.
Exactement. Ben on y croit dur comme fer.
Mais tu viens de m'expliquer que les gens avaient peur de se lancer. Et puis en plus de ça, on sait que dans les chiffres, les étudiants qui étudient l'informatique en Belgique, c'est 1,1 %.
C'est le ratio le plus petit de tous les pays de l'OCDE. Donc il y a pas beaucoup de gens qui étudient l'informatique.
Il y a pas vraiment une culture de l'entrepreneuriat. On a un petit pays qui est divisé. Quand Google arrive, quand on leur dit : « Hé, vous voulez pas faire un campus ici à Bruxelles ?
» Ils disent : « Non, c'est petit, c'est divisé. Non, bof, ça marchera pas. » Et toi, tu nous expliques que, en fait, c'est quand même la Silicon Valley européenne.
Et oui, parce que figure-toi qu'il y a un nouveau phénomène-
OK
...qui est en train de se passer. C'est un retour de tous les entrepreneurs de la Silicon Valley en Europe. Donc il faut savoir que la Silicon Valley est essentiellement finalement composée, ben, d'entrepreneurs européens.
Mmm-hmm.
Et ça devient un peu n'importe quoi de vivre à San Francisco et dans la Silicon Valley quand tu sais qu'il te faut au moins cinq cent mille euros, cinq cent mille dollars pour pouvoir payer tes bureaux pendant l'année, tu vois.
Donc à un moment donné, ça devient un peu du grand n'importe quoi. Et du coup, t'as ce phénomène de plein d'entrepreneurs, ben, qui reviennent au bercail, qui reviennent en Europe et qui reviennent aussi, bah, en Belgique.
Et ça, c'est intéressant. Alors bien sûr, ça va pas devenir la Silicon Valley, la nouvelle Silicon Valley, pour demain.
Mmm-hmm.
Mais il se trouve que, ben, Bruxelles, c'est quand même stratégique, c'est la capitale de l'Europe. Et ben, en termes de logement, c'est quand même extrêmement intéressant.
Et oui, on pense que bientôt, il y aura suffi-- il y aura un écosystème tech qui sera suffisamment développé et innovant qui pourra permettre aussi à d'autres entreprises étrangères de venir s'installer.
Mmm-hmm. Quand on pense aux pôles startup, aux pôles tech en Europe, on pense à Paris, on pense à Berlin, on pense à Londres.
Et on pensera bientôt à Bruxelles. Regarde, la scène tech en Belgique, elle a commencé quand ? En 2008 avec le Beta Group. Tu vois ?
OK. Où c'était ?
Ça fait dix ans. Et t'as vu le chemin qu'on a fait ? Avant, il y avait rien. Et en l'espace de dix ans, on a créé des marques, on a-- MolenGeek, on arrive à même le pitcher aux Nations unies.
Mmm-hmm.
Donc bon, on reçoit des prix de Samsung à Séoul.
Il y a des exemples similaires à Londres, à Berlin et à Paris.
Mais voilà. Mais avant, il y avait rien. Et comme tu dis, on est un petit pays. Donc on est en train de faire et on est en train de vraiment, je pense, de faire connaître la Belgique-
D'accord, je suis d'accord pour dire qu'on est en train d'un peu rattraper notre retard et que-
Ouais
...on a bien avancé. Non, je suis désolé, mais quand on voit qu'on est des tout derniers du classement de la culture d'entreprise, que les gens créent pas leur boîte ici, que les gens n'étudient pas l'informatique,
tu vois, moi, j'ai un peu du mal à trouver des gens avec un profil semblable au mien, un peu entrepreneurial, un peu tech, etc.
Oui, mais toi, t'as un profil très particulier, mais t'en-
C'est le profil Silicon Valley.
Déjà, si tu venais plus à MolenGeek, t'en trouverais d'autres, des tech guys avec des profils d'entrepreneurs.
Non, mais il y en a, il y en a, Guillaume. Et franchement, moi, je serais pas si sceptique que ça. Et je pense que vraiment, effectivement, Alexander De Croo et
en particulier essayent de vraiment de faire en sorte-- et puis toutes les initiatives qui sont,
sur ces thématiques entrepreneuriales innovantes puis nouvelles technologies, je pense qu'on fait beaucoup de bien à la Belgique et on essaye de faire en sorte que-- d'avoir un point de chute pour toutes ces entreprises.
Il y a un beau rayonnement international.
Je crois que tu es très optimiste et que je suis très pessimiste. On verra, on verra qui a raison.
On verra.
La vérité peut-être entre les deux, on verra. Ouais, mais donc je parlais de l'article qui est passé dans La Libre, La Libre Belgique, il y a quelques mois.
Vous faites beaucoup de presse, vous passez à la télé, vous passez dans les médias, dans les journaux, à la radio, aux Nations unies, sur le site de Samsung, etc.
Donc c'est vraiment beaucoup, beaucoup de communication. Alors que finalement, les places ici à MolenGeek, elles sont relativement limitées.
Donc il y a un an, c'était encore une vingtaine de personnes. Maintenant, tu me dis que ça s'est élargi ou quoi ?
Il y a un an, une vingtai-- non, non, non, pas du tout. Il y a un an, écoute, les chiffres, c'était en-
Je parle de la Coding School.
De la Code-- ah oui, oui, d'accord. La Coding School, oui.
Donc beaucoup de communication alors que les places sont relativement limitées. Est-ce que ça peut pas se retourner contre vous à terme de faire autant de communication, autant parler de vous ?
Grande demande pour s'inscrire à la Coding School. Vous pouvez pas recevoir tout le monde.
Non, on peut pas recevoir tout le monde. Mais maintenant qu'on a agrandi, on a vraiment augmenté nos capacités, ben d'accueil.
Et puis, le premier étage, les quatre cent mètres carrés, je peux te dire, on peut accueillir-- on a cinq classes.
Mmm-hmm.
Donc il y a de quoi faire pour accueillir.
Et donc justement, le processus de sélection, combien de demandes, combien de personnes qui sont candidates pour s'inscrire à la Coding School chaque fois ?
En moyenne, on a un peu plus de cent personnes qui viennent-
Cent personnes. Et au final, vous en gardez combien ?
...par notre source d'info et on en garde vingt maximum. Grand maximum. Donc alors, comment ça se passe ?
Et je pensais que ça s'était élargi. Tu me disais vingt maximum, mais...
Bah c'est des classes de vingt. Donc t'as-
Des classes-- Oui, c'est ça. Mais donc-
C'est ça. Mais donc-
Vingt fois-
Oui, mais pour l'instant, à chaque fois, on faisait donc deux séances d'information par promotion. Mais on fait toujours ça d'ailleurs, deux séances d'information par promotion.
Et au total, on avait donc ouais, une centaine de personnes pour vingt places quoi.
OK. Et vous, vous les sélectionnez comment ? Sur quels critères ? C'est quoi, c'est quoi l'idée ?
Alors, y a pas de critères disqualifiants. Ce sont les jeunes eux-mêmes qui se rendent compte au travers d'un processus de sélection qui est assez long, s'ils sont faits pour être développeur ou pas.
Donc c'est pas à nous qu'allons les juger sous forme de test, comment ça se passe. Déjà, le fait de venir à la séance d'information, c'est déjà un bon point.
Ça veut dire que tu t'es,
t'es quand même motivé pour venir découvrir une nouvelle formation. Puis ensuite, deux jours plus tard, t'as une séance de test technique où ils apprennent toute la journée, ils commencent à apprendre le JavaScript.
Parce qu'on sait que le JavaScript, au sein de la formation-
C'est déjà un peu plus la pensée de la programmation.
Voilà, c'est le début de la pensée de la programmation. Et là, tu vois directement ceux qui ont la logique et ceux qui l'ont pas.
Et effectivement, pour devenir développeur, hein, tout le monde peut pas l'être. Et si t'as pas cette logique, t'as beau travailler, ben, tu l'as pas, tu l'as pas.
Ce serait compliqué.
OK.
Et puis, pendant cette journée, t'as aussi un entretien avec le staff pour déterminer ton parcours de vie,
pour voir si justement, t'as un parcours stable, si t'as besoin d'être mis en contact avec des assistants sociaux,
pour, j'sais pas moi, trouver un logement, si t'es endetté, si t'as des problèmes comme ça, parce que c'est une, encore une fois, c'est une formation de six mois qui est très intensive.
Ouais, il faut venir tous les jours.
Donc si, à un moment donné, t'as plus de logement ou t'as vraiment des gros-- t'as besoin d'argent et que tu dois travailler, le fait d'arrêter et d'interrompre ta formation,
ça va tout casser et tu pourras plus continuer, en fait.
Vous avez déjà eu ça ? Vous avez déjà eu ça aux-- les premières années ?
Ouais, on a déjà eu ça. C'est pour ça qu'on est très vigilants par rapport à ça et on fait en sorte que les jeunes soient en ordre pour intégrer la formation.
Et puis ensuite, t'as un entretien autour de la motivation et puis on regarde un peu ce que t'as fait au cours de la journée.
Donc y a pas du tout-- t'es pas du tout jugé par ce que tu fais. T'es pas jugé si tu poses des questions aux autres, si tu poses des questions au coach, si tu t'entraides avec d'autres.
Au contraire, c'est beaucoup plus recommandé. Donc ça va nous paraître un peu suspicieux si t'as un petit jeune qui va pas dire un mot, qui va rester dans son coin et qui va être un peu introverti.
Bon voilà, on va faire attention.
On le serait mal jugé s'il est vraiment motivé.
Bah, on va faire attention parce que si tu veux, nous, on doit avoir une bonne équipe, un, comment dire, un effet dynamique, hein, de groupe.
Et ça, c'est important. Donc ça, c'est vraiment la séance d'information. Suivie, séance d'information test technique, suivie de quoi ?
D'une coding week. Donc c'est une semaine pour apprendre à créer un premier site internet. Donc là, ils font HTML, CSS, Bootstrap.
Et là, c'est chouette parce que ils rentrent dans le code et pendant quatre jours, ils apprennent et ils font leur premier site qu'ils présentent le vendredi.
Au-delà des critères qui sont donc la situation sociale, la motivation, etc., y a rien d'autre ? Par exemple, je suis toujours étonné.
Donc vous arrivez à avoir 40 % de femmes sans faire de discrimination positive alors.
Oui, sans faire de discrimination positive. Donc,
je parle de la coding week. Donc entre les séances, le test technique et l'entretien et la coding week, t'en as certains, déjà après la journée de JavaScript, qui te disent : « Bah, c'est pas pour moi du tout », quoi, tu vois.
Donc y en a certains qui abandonnent. Et puis, ils font la coding week et puis t'en as encore d'autres qui vont abandonner en se disant : « Bah non, mais moi, je me vois pas du tout coder toute la journée, c'est pas du tout pour moi ».
Et puis après, t'as encore un test, c'est une journée où ils font des jeux de société. Et puis là, on repère. Ouais, et là, on repère un peu leur attitude-
Ah c'est intéressant ça
...au sein du groupe, en fait.
On appelle team playing, le fait d'être positif ou le fait d'être emmerdant.
Bah de prendre le lead ou d'écraser les autres, tu vois. Et ça, le fait de jouer à des jeux comme ça, ça permet un peu de révéler un peu ta personnalité.
Est-ce que je peux te donner un exemple ? Est-ce que vous avez déjà filtré quelqu'un sur base d'un truc qui s'est passé quand il a joué à Monopoly ou un truc comme ça ?
Bah alors, c'est pas vraiment un Monopoly, c'est des jeux de rôle où tu dois trouver un peu des-
D'accord
...t'es un peu un Sherlock Holmes, comme ça tu dois trouver des indices et tout. Mais oui, on a déjà repéré des gens qui avaient tendance à écraser les autres.
Et donc dans un petit groupe de quinze, vingt personnes, dans une classe, si t'as quelqu'un qui est un peu une terreur et qui va écraser les autres, ça pourra pas fonctionner.
Les autres membres du groupe ne pourront pas poser des questions, ne pourront pas évoluer.
Donc c'est important d'avoir un groupe qui est homogène, soudé. Et c'est ce qu'on arrive à faire d'ailleurs.
La dernière promo, la promo quatre, en dehors de MolenGeek, ils se voient, ils sont soudés, ils font des activités ensemble, ils ont même créé des liens avec la promo trois.
Donc ça, c'est formidable.
Cool. Très bien Julie, mais je vais devoir bientôt te libérer. Mais juste avant, j'avais envie de te poser une question sur les autres initiatives qu'on voit arriver à Bruxelles.
Les-- y a eu BeCode, y a eu l'École 19, y a eu Interface 3 qui-- mais comment est-ce que vous voyez cette concurrence ?
Est-ce que c'est vraiment de la concurrence ? Est-ce que c'est une concurrence saine ? Est-ce que vous vous détestez entre vous ?
Comment est-ce que-- est-ce que MolenGeek a une particularité que les autres n'ont pas ? Comment ça marche ?
Bah écoute, non, je pense que c'est une concurrence saine. On n'a pas du tout le même public cible. Par exemple, Interface 3, on le sait, c'est des chercheuses d'emploi ou des femmes.
Donc ça, c'est formidable parce que ça permet justement à des femmes de pouvoir apprendre à coder dans un chouette environnement.
C'est des formations qui sont beaucoup plus longues, hein. Parfois, elles sont-
Sont un an
...c'est un an. Voilà. Ensuite, tu as l'École 19. Bon bah là, c'est trois ans de formation grand maximum, je crois.
Par exemple, moi, je me souviens, juste pour ma propre expérience, quand j'ai passé mon bac, j'avais le choix entre aller en prépa HEC ou aller à la fac.
Ben moi, la fac, c'était hors de question parce qu'à l'époque, j'avais besoin de structure. Le fait de m'autogérer, de travailler toute seule, c'était mission impossible.
Alors t'imagines, pour des jeunes qui, sans encadrement, c'est un peu compliqué. Et puis enfin, BeCode, c'est ce qui se rapproche un peu le plus de nous.
Mais pareil, ils sont, c'est une approche par projet. Oui, ils sont vraiment très autonomes dès le début.
Et puis le public est un peu différent parce que t'as un peu de reconversion professionnelle aussi dedans. Nous, notre méthodo, elle est vraiment unique en fait, elle est vraiment différente parce qu'on--
les jeunes ne sont jamais à aucun moment lâchés seuls.
Ils sont-- il y a toujours ce contrôle du début à la fin.
Et du coup, qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour les années à venir à MolenGeek, au-delà des projets d'extension, etc.
? Qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez voir améliorer, voir grandir ?
Bah MolenGeek, c'est un point de chute hein, et puis c'est vraiment une alternative pour tous ces jeunes.
Je pense que c'est important d'avoir toujours un maximum de visibilité. On a une véritable responsabilité, Ibra et moi, parce que t'as plein de jeunes qui comptent sur nous, justement pour avoir, pour trouver une place dans la vie.
Ça fonctionne. On a trouvé vraiment une méthodo qui fonctionnait et on fait vraiment des merveilles. Et pour nous, c'est vraiment hyper gratifiant quand t'as six mois auparavant des jeunes qui, pff, qui savaient pas quoi faire et
pour qui c'était vraiment problématique et qui étaient complètement perdus, de les voir embaucher par des grandes boîtes ou monter leur entreprise.
Pour nous, c'est vraiment la plus belle-
La consécration.
Ouais, c'est la plus belle victoire pour nous.
Ok, donc on vous souhaite en gros de continuer sur cette lancée et aussi d'arriver tout doucement à une rentabilité, si je comprends bien.
Bah la rentabilité, oui, on y arrive, on y arrive, hein, y a pas de problème pour ça.
Ok, cool. Julie, merci.
Bah merci Guillaume.
Merci d'avoir passé 70 minutes avec moi. Et on se revoit dans deux semaines. Bye bye. Et voilà, c'est déjà fini pour cet épisode.
Alors oui, je sais que l'émission s'appelle 70 minutes avec alors qu'en vrai, pour le coup, c'était plutôt 50 minutes. Mais voilà, comme on l'a dit, Julie est super méga occupée tout le temps, donc c'est comme ça.
N'oubliez pas de suivre 70 minutes avec sur Facebook et Twitter. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner sur votre appli de podcast préférée et de laisser plein d'étoiles sur iTunes.
Et j'en profite pour dire que l'émission est maintenant aussi dispo sur Spotify et YouTube. Je vous avais promis une annonce, alors la voici.
Ça fait des mois que je bosse sur un article écrit. Ça s'appelle Des souris et que des hommes. Ça parle d'un sujet qui m'obsède depuis quelques années, à savoir le fait qu'en Belgique, il y a très très peu d'étudiantes en informatique.
L'article est assez long, il est très complet. Ça parle de sociologie, ça parle d'histoire de l'informatique, ça parle d'économie, d'enseignement catholique, ça parle de l'histoire de la Belgique.
Voilà, tout ça pour dire que j'ai vraiment bossé dessus. Et d'ailleurs, c'est comme ça que ce podcast a démarré, puisque toutes les rencontres que j'ai pu faire ces derniers mois avec le ministre, avec Interface 3, avec Isabelle Collet, etc.
C'était avant tout pour me renseigner et maîtriser le sujet. Je vous invite à checker ça. Vous trouverez le lien sur les réseaux sociaux ou bien sur Google en tapant tout simplement le titre Des souris et que des hommes.
N'hésitez pas à le lire. Je me suis vraiment donné. J'espère que ça va vous plaire et j'ai hâte d'avoir votre feedback. Allez, on se retrouve dans deux semaines. Bye bye.